[موسيقى]
في البداية ، قد تكون العلامات غير واضحة في
طريقك إلى الخروج من الطريق السريع ،
متجاهلة ما تحتاجه في متجر
البقالة ووضع مفاتيحك في غير مكانها ، انظر إلى
هاتفي واقرأ
الأسماء والكثير منها لا يعني لي شيئًا
عن حياتك  Marches On بشكل مستقل
ولكن علامات الذاكرة
بدأت تتلاشى ببطء بالتأكيد وهذا ما
يشعر به مرض الزهايمر المبكر
عندما أصيب جاك دريسكول البالغ من العمر 80 عامًا
بتشخيصه الخاص بمرض الزهايمر في عام 2019
، كان على ما يرام ، لكنه كان قلقًا بشأن
مستقبله الذي تحدثت إليه في النهاية.
تحدثت أنا وزوجتي
إلى أطفالي وأخبرتهم أنه ربما
على الطريق
لن أكون كما كنت في
ذلك الوقت ،
لذا في عام 2021 ، التحق جاك
بتجربة إكلينيكية لعقار تجريبي يسمى
خريطة لا كندا التي تمت الموافقة عليها للتو  أظهرت إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية أن هذا
الدواء يمكن أن
يؤجل مصير أولئك الذين يعانون من
مرض الزهايمر المبكر جزئيًا عن طريق إزالة
لويحات الأميلويد من الدماغ ،
نجد أن هذا النوع المحدد من
الأميلويد عند إزالته في الواقع  وجدت
أو يرتبط بتباطؤ
التدهور المعرفي ، وأهمها
التجارب السريرية للدواء
أنه أبطأ التدهور المعرفي لدى الأشخاص
المصابين بمرض ألزهايمر المبكر بنسبة 27 في المائة ،
ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
وفقًا للنماذج التي قدمها صانع الدواء
شخصًا يبلغ من العمر 80 عامًا مثل جاك يمكن أن
يواجه  تأخير لمدة سنتين إلى ثلاث سنوات
في تفاقم
مرض الزهايمر ، لقد كنا نستهدف
مرض الزهايمر في المرحلة النهائية
عندما يصاب الأشخاص بالخرف حيث
لم يعد بإمكانهم الاعتناء بأنفسهم في
علم الأمراض وتراكمت اللويحات
والتشابك و  بحلول ذلك الوقت
، لم يكن هناك قدر ما يمكننا القيام به ولكن
لا شيء يأتي بدون مخاطر
والأدوية التي تأتي مع هذا النوع من الأدوية قد
أثارت علامات الخطر التي عرفناها منذ
سنوات عديدة أنه مع جميع الأدوية تقريبًا
في هذه الفئة يمكن أن يكون هناك  الآثار
الجانبية للدكتورة شارون كوهين
تدرس أدوية مرض الزهايمر منذ 30
عامًا وكانت جزءًا من التجربة
السريرية لما تتحدث عنه
آريا.  هو
شذوذ في التصوير يتعلق بالأميلويد ، يمكن أن يبدو مثل هذا أو
هذا ، إنه تورم في المخ أو نزيف في المخ ، على
الرغم من أن كوهين يقول إن هذه الأنواع
من الآثار الجانبية كانت في الغالب خفيفة في
التجربة ، فنحن نعلم أن خريطة Canon بها
معدل منخفض للتسبب في حدوث هدم كبير ليس
بالضرورة مميتًا ولكن  بمعدل منخفض أقل
من واحد في المائة في المرحلة الثالثة من
التجربة السريرية ، كان هناك سبع وفيات
في مجموعة الدواء الوهمي وستة وفيات في
مجموعة لوكانتيماب وفقًا
للمحققين على الرغم من عدم اعتبار أي من
الديون بسبب locanaman
أو Arya The New England Journal  من
الطب مؤخرًا تفاصيل
وفاة إضافية لمريض على
العقار الذي تم إعطاؤه مسيلات للدم
مما يثير مخاوف إضافية من
الصعب جدًا القول أن catamab يسبب ذلك
عند إعطاء دواء يمكن أن يتسبب في حد ذاته في
نزيف كبير ولكن
المزيج يعطي  نحن نتوقف مؤقتًا ، طبيب الأعصاب
الدكتور ريتشارد إيزاكسون يوافق على أنه بينما
يظهر هذا الدواء واعدًا ، يجب أن يأتي
بحذر على سبيل المثال  تجنب مميعات الدم
أثناء تناول الدواء
سأصف هذا الدواء
للشخص المناسب بالجرعة المناسبة
وبطريقة مراقبة دقيقة للغاية ولكن هذا الدواء
ليس للجميع بالنسبة لجاك
إمكانية الاستمرار في عيش حياة كاملة
وقضاء وقت ممتع مع الجميع  أربعة
أطفال وجميع الأحفاد التسعة حتى
لفترة أطول وهذا
يستحق المخاطرة بقدر ما أشعر بالقلق
لأننا نعيش حياة رائعة الآن
والأشياء جيدة واه
زوجتي راعية رائعة لذلك
نحصل عليها  مع بعضنا البعض ونعرف
ما نعيشه مع
تقرير الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا على شبكة سي إن إن